[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER: Shanghai
GDG is a very
interesting developer community.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
MALE SPEAKER: This is where
the magic happens.
FEMALE SPEAKER: This is
primarily a question and
answer show.
So if any of you out there would
like to ask questions?
FRED SAUER: All right,
welcome everyone.
Thanks for joining today.
My name is Fred Sauer.
I'm a developer advocate
working on App Engine.
And with me today--
IEIN VALDEZ: Iein Valdez.
I'm also a developer advocate
working on Google App Engine.
FRED SAUER: So today we thought
we'd talk to you a
little bit about load testing
on App Engine and some
performance tuning tips, so how
to get prepared for when
your app is finally
successful.
So I wanted to start off and
just share with you a few
graphs from one of
our customers.
I picked out some of the bigger
events that they had.
This is a company that
does social events.
So they have a gadget that they
put on other people's
websites, and people can chat
on this gadget and interact
with each other.
And depending on the excitement
of the event, be it
a sporting event or something
like that, different things
happen to the traffic
patterns.
So at any point when you're
looking at the traffic graphs,
you don't know what it's
going to do next.
Is it going to go up?
Is it going down?
Are you going to get 10x the
traffic that you had a few
minutes ago?
Or are you going to get
half the traffic?
And, so you see the
graphs here.
And a couple of interesting
things is that, well, these
are the most popular events
between the smallest one--
I've left out the -scale here,
but there's a 10x difference
between the largest event and
the smallest one shown here.
The other thing is, if you look
at the time scale, this
is over several hours.
So even though there's really
kind of sharp increases, if
you were to zoom in, kind of on
a minute scale, you would
still see what we call kind of
a gradual ramp, and I'll come
back to that in a moment--
IEIN VALDEZ: So these are good
graphs, is what you're saying.
This is ideal performance?
FRED SAUER: This is just
input to the system.
This is customers showing up on
your website, knocking on
the door, and saying I
want to do something.
IEIN VALDEZ: Right.
But in other words, it didn't
like drop off to zero?
In other words, it
didn't lock up.
FRED SAUER: This is success.
IEIN VALDEZ: OK, that's--
yeah, so these are good
graphs, I guess, OK.
FRED SAUER: Yeah, and then on
the edges of these graphs,
there's pretty much
nothing going on.
When the gadget's not live on an
event, there's pretty much
no traffic, just a little bit
of background with people
refreshing maybe a homepage
or something like that.
So App Engine is this
distributed computing platform.
And to really understand how it
works, and do performance
tuning, and understand how your
load tests are kind of
flowing through the system,
you need to kind of break
apart the different components
and understand why we call it
a distributed system and why
that's really important to the
characteristics of App Engine.
So if you kind of look here from
left to right, you have
the clients that are producing
traffic-- so web browsers,
mobile phones--
and they're sending requests
into App Engine.
And the first thing they
do is they hit
the front end servers.
These are the servers that take
care of opening up the
HTTP communication with the
client serving the responses,
and then they direct the traffic
down deeper into the
depths of the Google
App Engine network
and on to other servers.
You may have back end servers.
You may be using the datastore
or memcache, or maybe the
image manipulation service.
And so each time you make a
call, you're going from an app
server, which is running your
code, down another layer into
datastore, memcache,
et cetera.
Now to zoom in a little bit on
the datastore there, when you
write an entity to the
datastore, say, and then that
makes an RPC-- a Remote
Procedure Call--
to a tablet server, that tablet
server is responsible
for a chunk of your data, and
that tablet server then has to
write to a physical disk.
So I haven't listed all the
layers here, but you see we
already have--
after the client, we
have a front end.
There's an app server.
There's a tablet server.
Then there's the physical disk,
and there's a few more
bits of infrastructure
in between there.
IEIN VALDEZ: I guess the thing
to point out is that the front
ends and the tablet servers
and all that stuff is auto
scaled for you.
You don't really actually
have to manage it.
So whether you have one request
coming in or 10,000,
that is all scaled by
the infrastructure.
FRED SAUER: Exactly.
And so our mission today is to
understand how to utilize this
infrastructure in a way that it
continues to scale for us,
that we don't introduce--
use any patterns where we
actually kind of defeat the
system and turn it into a
non-distributed system.
Because that's really the one
way in which you can hurt the
performance of your
application.
IEIN VALDEZ: Cool.
FRED SAUER: So we'll talk about
that a little bit more.
So still zooming in on the
datastore at the very lowest
level, every entity that you
store in the datastore is
ultimately stored in a big table
row in this giant key
value store.
So every entity that you have
has a key, and then in the
data portion, you have all
the properties, the
values of your entity.
Even the index entries
are in this form.
So if you have an entity, say,
a customer, and you have a
first name and a last name,
and both properties are
indexed, you'll actually
have one row in this
table for the entity.
You'll have another row for
the built-in index entity.
And then you'll have
four different
rows for the property.
You'll actually have a first
name ascending index, a
descending, and a last name
ascending and descending.
So think of your data as spread
out in this giant table
of key value pairs, and
every bit of data is
addressable by key.
And then there's some
data associated with
it, which is useful.
Now, this is really important
because different parts of
your data live in different
parts of the disk.
And in order to take advantage
of the distributed nature of
App Engine, you need to make
sure that not all your quests
from all your users are
going to a single
block of data on disk.
Because if you do that,
there's ultimately--
somewhere in a Google data
center, there's a server that
is responsible for, let's say,
this little red block of data
right there.
Just these few rows of data,
there's one server that's
responsible.
And it has to be just one server
because we want to
allow atomic transactions
on that data.
So think about it that way.
Now, imagine that one of these
rows of red data is some
global state in your
application.
Maybe it's a page counter, and
every time a visitor comes to
the site, you want to increment
this counter and
record the fact that you
had another visitor.
Now, let's say you are very
successful, and you're serving
1,000 requests per second,
maybe 10,000
requests per second.
All those requests have to
then funnel down from all
these different front end
servers to all these different
datastore servers, all the way
down to the single tablet
server, which is now very much
getting overloaded because
it's having to write to disk
10,000 times a second.
And if you know anything about
disk hardware, you know that
that's just simply
not possible.
So one of the key strategies
in utilizing App Engine is
making sure that you distribute
your load.
So if you wanted to have this
page counter and you wanted to
be able to update it at, say,
10,000 requests per second,
that's absolutely possible.
You just need to distribute
it over many
different blocks of data.
And this is a strategy called
sharding or partitioning.
And what you do is you say,
well, instead of having one
counter that we store in one
row in the datastore, let's
make 1,000 counters, and let's
randomize the keys.
They don't have to
be truly random.
They just have to be distributed
over key space.
So just for the sake
of argument, let's
say we had 26 keys.
We could prefix our global page
visitor counter with the
letter of the alphabet.
So we could have A page counter,
B page counter, C
page, all the way to
Z page counter.
And then any time a request
comes in and we want to bump
up this page counter, we pick
one of the keys at random-- it
really doesn't matter
which one--
so we could just take a random
function times 1,000, or 26,
or however many characters
we have, and then
we update that row.
And now what suddenly has
happened, instead of having
10,000 requests going to a
single tablet server, we've
distributed over, say, 1,000
tablets servers, each one
doing only 10 requests
per second.
That's maybe a lot
more reasonable.
IEIN VALDEZ: So, you're
basically reducing the lock
and write contention over
a set of keys by
distributing it out.
So it's sort of a fan
out pattern--
FRED SAUER: Exactly.
IEIN VALDEZ: --to increase
the amount of
concurrency in the system.
FRED SAUER: Yeah.
So you can see that what we're
kind of saying here is that
App Engine has this massive
distributed
infrastructure for you.
But you can definitely defeat
that infrastructure, if you
send all your writes to a single
key, if you choose your
keys poorly, or choose
your indexes poorly.
So there's a little bit of, I
guess, forethought that needs
to go into choices
of your design.
And you do that, and then
everything scales very nicely.
IEIN VALDEZ: And when we talk
about Bigtable, or the picture
we have here, we're talking now
in the new world sort of
in the high-replication
datastore world, which is
there's also issues you have
to worry about in terms of
consistency and how you
structure your entity groups
and whatnot as well.
FRED SAUER: Yeah, there's
definitely some design choices
to make beyond just selecting
your keys.
You talk about consistency, so
App Engine has this notion of
entity groups.
These are groups of entities
in which you can do atomic
operations.
So you can create a transaction,
and you can
manipulate multiple rows or
entities within that entity
group in a single transaction.
IEIN VALDEZ: Right.
FRED SAUER: And then new--
well, not quite so
new anymore.
It's probably been about six
or eight months now.
We have cross-group
transactions, XG transactions,
which if you're a long-time
customer of App Engine, you'll
remember the day when you
could only transact on a
single entity group.
Now you can actually do up to
five entity groups in a single
transaction.
IEIN VALDEZ: This is
transactions across entity
groups, and so this is really
nice for those complex
transactions.
FRED SAUER: Yeah, the canonical
case is I have money
in two bank accounts, and I'd
like to transfer money.
I want to deduct $10 out of this
account and add $10 to
that account, and I want to do
it in a single transaction.
And you can do that.
IEIN VALDEZ: Very cool.
FRED SAUER: So there's a number
of tools that App
Engine provides for your
tools for the trade.
One of them is called
Appstats.
And actually, in the 1.7.1
release that just went out
last week, there's an
enhancement that's not even
represented here
in screenshot.
There's a little shell mode
that allows you to type a
snippet of Python code and
actually see what the Appstats
would look like for that without
having to deploy your
application or test it.
So you can work on snippets
of code and optimize them.
Now, this is a great tool.
I love the quote here. "I used
to be blind, but now I can
see." And what the person meant
here is that they used
to blind to what was going
on in their application.
They could certainly read
through their code and see how
many datastore calls they
thought they were making.
But when you turn on Appstats,
you actually
get a visual overview.
And you can see that in this
case, there's kind of this
staircase effect, where one RPC
happens after the other,
after the other.
And that actually slows down
the requests quite a bit.
And it gives you hints.
I guess looking at this, you
can say, maybe I should use
some asynchronous fetches
so I can do
more things in parallel.
Maybe I can do a more
efficient query.
IEIN VALDEZ: You can batch
requests together so you can
make one round trip versus 100,
if you wanted to fetch
100 entities, for example.
FRED SAUER: Yes, exactly.
So first thing you should do
if you're optimizing your
application is turn
on Appstats.
You can use it in the
development server.
You can use it in production.
If you don't want to turn it
on for all of your live
traffic, you can deploy to
a separate version, a
non-default version of your
application, and turn it on
there, and then just play
with it yourself.
So let's start off with some
load testing guidelines.
First of all, your load
tests should really be
representative of the real
traffic that you expect.
That means the rate at which
you on-ramp traffic.
You should let traffic
ramp up over many
minutes when you're--
IEIN VALDEZ: You don't just have
a million users come to
your site right away, so testing
it in that example
probably is not--
FRED SAUER: And even if you--
people talk about getting
on slash dotted.
Or maybe you're on a popular
talk show, and you get
mentioned live on air, and you
think that everyone's going
to, at the same time,
hit the Enter key
and go to your website.
Well, in reality, some people
have the computer sitting on
their couch.
Other people have to get
up and walk over.
And the reality is, that even
then with some of the largest
events, you'll see
traffic ramp up.
IEIN VALDEZ: It ramps up.
FRED SAUER: So your
load test should
absolutely reflect that.
So this is not what
your traffic
graph should look like.
Save the example, right?
FRED SAUER: And you're just
going to see problems if
you're doing that.
It's the same thing if you're
driving a car, and you're at a
light, and you say, OK
go 100 miles an hour.
You don't pop the clutch and
instantly go 100 miles an
hour, right?
You have to pull out of your
spot, and you can go fast in a
short amount of time,
but take it easy.
So something like this is a lot
better, kind of ramped up.
And if you really wanted to do
it nice, you kind of smooth in
and out of the traffic.
So let's look at a basic
recipe here.
When you want to test traffic,
let's say your goal is 1,000
qps, 1,000 requests
per second.
If you were to just throw 1,000
on there, and even if
you use that nice little curve
from before, but let's say you
have some inefficiencies in
your app that you haven't
worked through yet, and those
inefficiencies would normally
kick up or start acting up at
20 requests per second.
If you then throw 1,000 at it,
you're not only going to see
all the errors caused by going
over the 20, but you're going
to see all the snowball
effect of that.
And your error logs are just
going to be a big mess, and
you won't be able to tell what's
going on because you've
just completely overloaded the
contentious spots in your
application.
And so what we want to do is
have a recipe where we get you
to 1,000, which is your target,
very quickly, But we
stop along the way to make sure
that we're in good shape,
and we can handle that
amount of traffic.
IEIN VALDEZ: And so we're sort
of progressively revealing
maybe performance problems as
you kind of go through.
Maybe there's five or six
different problems versus you
see all five or six at once, and
you can't actually figure
out what's going on.
FRED SAUER: That's
exactly right.
And I haven't met an application
that I wrote or
anyone else that I know wrote,
and I'm sure there's people
out there that write perfect
applications the first time.
But there's always scenarios you
haven't thought through.
Maybe there's places where you
said, oh, I'll come back and
do that, and then you've
got distracted.
And there's maybe
some unknowns.
So exactly.
We want to find those problems,
but we want to find
them one at a time.
Because problems generally are
really easy to address if you
have just that one problem.
If you have, for example, that
global page counter, that
problem is actually pretty easy
to find if that's the
only thing going on.
So here's a recipe.
We'll start out with something
small, like 5 qps, 5 requests
per second.
And we just keep sending 5
requests per second, and we
look for any problems.
If you actually had a global
page counter, this would
already show up at 5 qps,
because entity groups are
designed to handle
at least 1 qps.
Sometimes you can get a little
bit more out of it--
depending on whether you're
master, slave, it's your D--
but 5pqs is enough to find
issues like that.
And that's a small amount of
traffic where you can actually
just look through the logs
and you can see things.
But let's say you don't
have any issues there.
So what do you do?
You wait about 15 to 20 minutes,
and what you're
looking for is the dashboards
in the admin console.
You want to see essentially
a number of flat lines.
You want to see no quota
denials, which you certainly
won't see at this rate,
very low error rate.
There's always going to maybe be
some background error rate,
because you're in a large
distributed system.
You want to make sure
that your task
queues are keeping up.
You may want to ratchet up the
number of concurrent requests
there if you need to, and
no elevated datastore
contentions, so you don't
want to see a number
of datastore errors.
And so then what we do is we
double our traffic, but we do
it slowly over a period
of several minutes.
And what we're looking for
is the next application
bottleneck.
Now, if everything goes
smoothly, and again, we see
these flat lines, very low error
rate, no quota denials,
task queues are keeping up, we
just keep moving on, and we
repeat, and repeat until we
reach that 1,000 qps, or that
30 qps, or whatever number
we're shooting for there.
And once we're happy and we've
gotten to the desired amount
of traffic and have a very
stable, consistently
performing application, then we
plan our next feature and
go through the load testing
process again once we've
rolled out a major feature or
done any refactoring in the
application.
IEIN VALDEZ: is there a best
practice in terms of how
frequently you actually
do these things?
Or is it just when you're making
a major change, you
sort of do that?
I'm not sure what--
FRED SAUER: I think there's
always a trade-off.
In an ideal world,
you would have a
dedicated QA team, right?
And they would run your
application through the paces
for every single release
and make sure it works.
I know many of you, you might be
working by yourself or just
with one colleague, and
everything's a judgment call,
everything's a trade-off.
If you spend the day on load
testing, you don't get to
write this feature.
And so you really have to
decide, did I do some major
refactoring?
Or is this really just a tweak
to the CSS of the site?
IEIN VALDEZ: But it's definitely
the type of thing,
like if you're launching, you
probably want to do a major
load test run.
But then post-launch, let's
say you've ironed out.
You've got some minor
features.
Maybe it's not, but maybe if
you're changing the way you're
storing your data or you're
changing your queries, maybe
that would require something
like this.
FRED SAUER: Absolutely.
You should have a load test
before you launch big.
And any type of re-factoring
work's important.
IEIN VALDEZ: Make sure
you have billing on.
FRED SAUER: Oh, yes.
IEIN VALDEZ: Ratio is one of
those other things that some
people forget to turn on
until the last minute.
FRED SAUER: Yeah, so that's
a really good point there.
Because App Engine has these
free quotas, but your
application is much more
throttled because it's living
in this free world.
As soon as you turn on billing,
some of those
constraints come off and your
application is ready for some
really traffic.
IEIN VALDEZ: OK, cool.
FRED SAUER: So this slide here
is just to make a point about
the difference between the
amount of time that it takes
in our infrastructure if you
were running your own servers
to write to disk versus
to write to
memory over the network.
So when we start out building
applications, almost every
application needs some sort
of persistence in storage.
So we're always using the
datastore writing data to
disks, but we should really
realize that if you're doing
the lookup to disk, you'll lose
at least 20 milliseconds.
You might be closer to 50
or might even be 100
milliseconds, depending
on what's going on.
But doing a lookup over the
network, that can happen in
order of 10x faster.
So it's an order of
magnitude faster.
Now, if you're, in a single
request having to pull a
number of pieces of data
together that's 20
milliseconds here, 50
milliseconds there, another 30
there, that pretty soon starts
to add up to real change.
Whereas if you're making a few
calls to memcache, you can
make 10 of those, and you still
are only up to the speed
of one datastore call.
Now, for Python users out there,
I should just really
make a call out to NDB,
the new database API.
It does this for you
automatically.
So it introduces a caching
layer, and when you fetch from
the datastore, it automatically
checks memcache first.
In fact, it has another layer
in front of this that's even
faster, which is the context
memory of the instance.
IEIN VALDEZ: Instance caching.
FRED SAUER: Yeah, and for Java
users out there, there's
Objectify, which has a caching
scheme called Objectify Cache.
And you can turn that
on, and it gets a
lot of the same benefits.
IEIN VALDEZ: Awesome.
FRED SAUER: Now, let's talk
about free lunch.
I know right here in Mountain
View, it's not lunchtime yet.
But this looks pretty
tasty here.
IEIN VALDEZ: It does
look pretty good.
FRED SAUER: So how do you
get a free lunch?
There's a saying that there's no
such thing as a free lunch,
but I think there actually is.
Let me talk about that.
I just mentioned
using memcache.
But another thing that many
developers forget is to turn
on or use static resources.
So there are a lot of files in
your application which don't
change or change very
infrequently.
And you can turn those into
static resources, and they get
served through a different
path in App Engine's
infrastructure, a path
that doesn't even
take instance hours.
So you're saving yourself
instance hours.
The responses are faster for
your users, and ISPs and
others downstream can cache
this content as well.
IEIN VALDEZ: So let's just say
that I'm hosting a website
with some dynamic and
static content.
So like the images, the static
HTML, that stuff
you could serve up.
FRED SAUER: Exactly, put that
in the static resources.
And then even for your dynamic
requests, let's say you have
the homepage which you
dynamically put together, and
you have the top things that
just happened, and you have a
little news snippet,
and you have some
other stuff going on.
You say, well, I have to
generate that dynamically.
I can't do that statically.
Well, in fact, you don't need
that information probably to
be up to the microsecond, up to
date, every single time the
user requests the data.
Maybe it can be a few
seconds stale.
Maybe you could, if you have a
lot of traffic, only update
that data every 20 seconds.
Maybe every two minutes
is enough.
So if you set your cache control
headers and say this
page content, as it's generated,
is good for the
next two minutes, then every
user that comes in the next
two minutes, they can take
advantage of that cache
content, get a much faster
response, lower the load on
your site, lower your instance
hours, et cetera.
Saves you bandwidth.
IEIN VALDEZ: Very cool.
FRED SAUER: And that's where
the free lunch comes in.
When this content is cached
downstream at the ISP, say,
Iein and I live in the same
neighborhood, and we
have the same ISP.
And I just went and fetched
this page from this very
popular website, and then a few
minutes later, Iein goes
out and gets that same page.
That request might
never actually
come over to App Engine.
It might be served directly
out of the ISP's cache.
That's the free lunch
right there.
IEIN VALDEZ: Very cool.
So this is really important
for people
who are hosting websites.
Even if you're doing things in
the Chrome Web Store, we have
a lot of people hosting Chrome
Web apps that have all these
static resources.
That's really who should
take note.
FRED SAUER: And even little
bits of dynamic content.
Like you might have a leader
board showing the top five
players in your game.
Well, that information doesn't
change second by second.
IEIN VALDEZ: Right.
So maybe having a slightly
out-of-date copy every 30
seconds or minute
type of thing--
FRED SAUER: Exactly.
IEIN VALDEZ: --might be OK.
FRED SAUER: Yep.
IEIN VALDEZ: Very cool.
FRED SAUER: So just with some
small tweaks, you can reduce
the freshness of the data only
a tiny bit, but perhaps gain
very significantly.
And the nice thing is that these
caching benefits, they
actually are much more
prominent the
larger your site is.
The more traffic you're serving,
the more users, the
more opportunities
these caches have
to serve cache content.
So these things kind of
compound themselves.
So a couple more best practices,
and this is
particularly geared towards
those of you that are mobile
developers out there.
Because you have clients out
there, mobile devices, that
are running your software.
So maybe you've written an
Android app, and these
applications are under
your control.
And you can program them to call
home to request data from
your application.
So now instead of humans, who
are a little bit unpredictable
and they'll log on to your site
at different times of
day, now you have all these
Android devices out there in
the wild, maybe spread out
through your country or spread
out around the world, and
they're all sync to the same
network time, and they all
obey the same list of
instructions.
And what you have is actually a
mini botnet that is wired up
to connect to your
application.
So, this traffic graph right
here shows one of the bad
things that can happen when,
let's say you decide, I want
my Android app to call
home every day
at, let's say, midnight.
And you get a few users.
You get your friends using it.
It's fine.
And then suddenly, your
application becomes a little
bit popular, and now you have
thousands of people using your
application.
So there's thousands of Android
phones out there that
all at midnight, call home, call
your application at the
exact same time requesting
the same information.
And so you get these crazy
little spikes that happen.
And so you want to avoid that.
And it's quite easy to do.
You simply want to randomize
the check-in times.
So every client picks
a random time.
And if you still want to do it
at night, you could say, OK,
between 2:00 and 4:00 AM,
pick a random time on
the check-in net.
That's still a lot better than
a single point in time.
The other thing that once people
have tackled that is
developers will have
a built-in retry.
So if everything's
successful, fine.
Keep going on, pick
a random time.
But if the device encounters any
kind of error, then maybe
it retries say, two
minutes later.
Well, what happens when your
site goes down for
maintenance, for example?
So suddenly your site becomes
available to all clients.
And so they all start retrying
on, let's say,
a two-minute schedule.
And what you'll get is
actually one of these
heartbeat graphs, where every
two minutes, all these clients
try at the same time
to reach your site.
But that's too much of an
instantaneous and unrealistic
load, and so many of these
clients actually will get an
error message again.
So they'll retry two minutes
later, and so you create this
crazy little heartbeat.
So pretty simple, you do
something called exponential
backoff, which is you basically
do something like
double the retry time
every time you fail.
So you retry after 2 minutes,
then 4, then 8, then 16.
And this way, your overtime
reducing the load to your site
so that eventually it
will recover from
your own little botnet.
But the important thing that you
shouldn't forget here is,
again, the fuzz factor.
You have to randomize
it a bit.
Otherwise, these heartbeats just
become more spread out.
So there's a number
of best practices.
We have this article.
It's great.
It's kind of a checklist to go
through of performance issues
that you want to look at.
And it gives you some tools
to adjust between
performance and cost.
For some of your applications,
performance is the most
important thing, and you're
trying to get the most out of
App Engine as far as
serving resources
as quickly as possible.
For others of you, budget is a
little bit more important, and
you want to get more out of the
resources that you have.
And this article shows you some
of the trade-offs and is
at least a checklist of things
you should be aware of and
then you can dive deeper into to
each of the details there.
Here's a list, for example, of
ways to reduce instance hours,
which is when the primary
cost of--
primary sources of cost
for applications.
And the other one
is datastore.
We kind of did an informal
survey of how developers are
using their datastore.
And what we find is that almost
all developers are
using the datastore less
efficiently than they could.
One of the common ways to get
data back is to use a query.
In many cases, a query can be
replaced by a direct fetch to
an entity, which is
half the work.
Because a query involves first
doing a scan to an index, then
figuring out the keys,
and actually going
fetching those keys.
When you do a direct fetch for
a key, you skip that first
step entirely.
But even a fetch can
be more efficient.
If you only need to know the key
of an entity, you can do a
keys only query.
IEIN VALDEZ: There's projection
queries now.
FRED SAUER: Projection queries,
very good, yep, where
you pull in only the properties
you need.
IEIN VALDEZ: Right.
So if I have an entity with
maybe 100 properties but I
only need three at the moment,
I can just fetch those.
Those three--
FRED SAUER: Yes, exactly.
IEIN VALDEZ: -- and the cost
will reflect that.
FRED SAUER: Yeah, you'll get a
small datastore opp instead of
a large one, which there's
a big difference there.
Now a while back, we introduced,
in the admin
console, some of these
performance knobs.
And you won't see
these knobs--
you won't see all of them unless
you turn billing on.
So it's another reason
to turn on billing.
And these four knobs right here
really represent a way of
tuning cost versus
performance.
So a couple of the typical
things that you'll do is if
you want to make sure that your
application is all warmed
up, and you're ready to serve
a lot of traffic in a very
short period of time, and that's
the most important
thing for you, then you probably
want to raise Min
Idle Instances.
And that tells App Engine--
that's a signal to App Engine
to keep more instances warm
and ready in case there's a
sudden increase in traffic.
On the other hand, if you're
very cost sensitive and you'd
rather App Engine not spin up
another instance if it doesn't
need to because there's a short
little blip in traffic,
you can increase the Min
Pending Latency.
And that allows requests to
sit in a pending queue a
little while before
they trigger a new
instance to be started.
IEIN VALDEZ: Right.
I guess one of the things
I see a lot of is that
developers are always kind
of fiddling with these.
But sort of out of the box,
don't we say that that's
basically--
the settings that we give you
by default are pretty much
optimal to start with.
FRED SAUER: Absolutely.
IEIN VALDEZ: You should try
starting with those settings
before you actually mess with
the sliders and then sort of
tune your application
after that.
FRED SAUER: Yes, that's
a good point.
These are advanced settings.
And if you are having any
trouble with your application,
you should set these all back
to automatic and test there.
And then only when you
need something
in addition to those--
IEIN VALDEZ: Or maybe you need
to control your costs a little
bit or start making some
performance trade-offs.
Because I think that's the thing
I see a lot of beginners
or even intermediate people
tweaking this without really
understanding what's going on.
And there's these side effects
that they see in their
application that as soon as
they put the knobs back to
automatic, they sort
of go away.
FRED SAUER: Yeah.
When people reach out to us and
say they're having issues
with their application, if
they've adjusted these
settings, the very first
thing we'll say is,
let's put them back.
Let's do a load test or look at
traffic with everything set
to automatic, and then let's
make some small adjustments
from there.
These are definitely not knobs
that you swing from one
extreme to the other.
These are very fine tuning
for those advanced
users and use cases.
IEIN VALDEZ: And the other thing
I was going to ask is
front-end instance class.
So talk a little bit about that,
because that's actually
one thing in particular I'm
always interested in.
And I think a lot of developers
wonder what's the
difference between the F1
all the way up to the--
practice what you see.
FRED SAUER: OK, that's
a good point.
So we have front-ends
and back-ends.
Back-ends have instance
classes called
B1, B2, B4, and B8.
And those represent different
amounts of CPU and memory.
And then on the front end we
have F1, F2, and F4, I
believe, is the largest
instance.
So for most applications, the
defaults of F1 are fine, but
for certain types of
applications it can be very
advantageous to actually switch
to a higher class.
And the reasons you would do
this, a very simple one is if
you need to have a lot of
instance memory, like there's
a lot of state that
you want to key.
IEIN VALDEZ: Like I have a lot
of data structures that I'm
storing locally.
FRED SAUER: Exactly.
So if you're running out of
memory, that's kind of an
automatic trigger you need to be
in a higher instance class.
And that's kind of
the easy case.
The trickier one to understand
is the CPU one.
So the way it works is when you
have an F1 instance, think
of it as having a fraction of a
CPU, the way that we used to
do time sharing.
So in, say, a second, 1,000
milliseconds, you get time
slices within that for your
request to be handled.
If you have multithreading
turned on, you actually have
multiple requests going
through your
instance at the same time.
But those requests, they run for
a little bit, and then you
can think of them as being
paused, and then running again
if they're on an F1 class.
Now, if you have a pretty simple
application and you're
not doing a lot of
CPU, most of it's
what we call I/O bound.
So you get a request, and you
immediately make a call to the
data store, and then you're
just waiting for the
datastore to return.
And then you put together a
bunch of strings, template,
then ship the result out.
That's a very CPU un-intensive
application.
IEIN VALDEZ: So F1 is great,
perfect for that.
FRED SAUER: F1 is probably
just great for that.
But if you're doing some
computation or you're waiting
less, there's less I/O going
on, you may actually end up
being CPU bound.
That is, your application is
ready to do some calculations,
and then it's actually idled for
a short while, and then it
comes back alive,
and idled again.
And what's happening is your
requests are thereby taking
longer than they
really need to.
So by switching to a higher
instance class, you actually
get a fuller fraction
of the CPU.
And that allows your request to
actually keep running until
it's finished, and then
immediately return.
And so depending on your
application, it may very well
be that, if you switched to
a F4 front-end class, even
though those instance hours are
more expensive, it may be
cheaper to run your
application on
that instance class.
IEIN VALDEZ: Because I can get
more in that request versus
maybe a bunch of F1s that would
take me to process that.
FRED SAUER: Yeah, your request
will finish sooner, which
means, in total, you need fewer
instances running to
handle all your concurrent
requests.
IEIN VALDEZ: Now, would Appstats
help me figure that
out a little bit?
Or is that--
FRED SAUER: A little bit.
IEIN VALDEZ: Because I'm trying
to figure out how do
you actually figure that
out when I need to--
or is it sort of just the
fiddling with it and sort of
experimentation?
FRED SAUER: I think really the
best way of doing this is to
actually change the instance
hours in a controlled setting.
So a load test is
a great example.
Run a load test, and once the
load test is clean, it's error
free, you figured out your
bottlenecks, and now the thing
is just running very smoothly,
get one of these slow ramp-up
load tests to your target,
say, that was 1,000 qps.
And you let it run for
half an hour on F1s.
And you let it do the same thing
over again you run it
for half an hour on F4s.
And just see what the instance
hours looks like, what the
costs look like.
IEIN VALDEZ: I could look at
the request latency, and
probably see other things
just to sort of see--
FRED SAUER: The cost might be
identical, but your clients
might receive responses
more quickly.
So your users are happier, which
means more usage to your
site, maybe more traffic,
more revenue.
IEIN VALDEZ: Very cool.
FRED SAUER: So that's a great
feature that people
need to look at.
And also the Page Speed service,
which we launched at
Google I/O, takes care of all
these static resource
optimizations, rewriting HTML,
and CSS, and JavaScript, and
just optimizing the resources.
IEIN VALDEZ: So that's one
level further than the
original caching we talked
about, where it actually
introspects into your HTML, CSS,
JavaScript, and rewrites
stuff for you.
FRED SAUER: Exactly.
It takes all the white
space out.
It takes the comments out.
It can actually change the
JavaScript and take these long
variable names and squish them
down to little ones, making
things more efficient.
It has a number of default
settings and default rewriters.
But if you do some
experimentation, there's some
optional ones that you can turn
on that will actually in
line more JavaScript
more aggressively.
So the way the Page Speed
service works is there's say
20 rewriters, and each one has
a specific capability.
There's a CSS rewriter that gets
rid of white space and
comments and gets rid of CSS
that is orphaned, things that
won't do anything.
There's an HTML rewriter.
There's a JavaScript rewriter.
And so a number of those are
generally safe, and they're
turned on by default.
And there's some that are
potentially unsafe, depending
on your application.
And those you can turn on
manually after you've
confirmed that they basically
don't hurt your application.
And if you turn all the
aggressive options on, you can
really get some nice
improvements as far as
response times from
your application.
IEIN VALDEZ: Very cool.
Before you go to the next slide,
I just wanted to remind
everyone that's watching us
live, we're going to the
questions in a bit.
So if you have specific
performance questions that you
want Fred and I to talk about,
go ahead and put them in the
Moderator link.
Now would be a great
time to do that.
And then, in a few
minutes, we'll
go through the questions.
FRED SAUER: Great.
IEIN VALDEZ: Sorry, just
don't want people to
miss out on the questions.
FRED SAUER: We want more.
We want more of your
questions.
We're here to answer
them for you.
Now one thing to not forget,
and I know the way that
happens with presentations is
you hear a lot of this stuff,
and you kind of remember the
first thing that was said, and
the last thing that was said.
So one of the last slides here,
I wanted to make sure
would be one of the things you
would remember, which is to
enable warmup requests.
And the App Engine Scheduler
has this job of trying to
predict what your traffic's
going to look like, say, a
second from now.
So it looks at all the traffic
that's coming in.
It looks at all the requests
that are in flight and what
the average latency or the
average response time of those
requests is, and then it tries
to predict whether it will
soon, momentarily, need
a new instance or not.
But it can only warm up
instances in advance if it
predicts so, or you tell it so
with Min Idle Instances, and
only if you enable
warmup requests.
Now, warmup requests are kind of
a special internal request
that App Engine will send
to new instances of your
application to make them ready
to serve live traffic.
Without this, you'll have what
we call a cold instance, one
that hasn't seen any traffic
yet, hasn't been initialized.
And one of your user requests is
going to come to your site
and say, I'd like the
homepage, please.
This request will go to this
cold instance, and the request
is going to have to sit there
and wait for your application
to initialize.
Maybe you fetch some global
data, and you have to make a
few round trips to the datastore
and collect a few
things and kind of get your
house of cards in order before
you're able to serve
that response.
That's all time that your
client is waiting.
When you have a warmup request,
App Engine can,
without affecting user latency,
send a special little
request to your application.
Your application can initialize
quietly behind the scenes.
And then when it's all ready to
go, it's nice and hot, then
the first user request comes
along and hits that instance.
So be sure to enable
warmup requests.
When you have them, you'll see
these requests in the log
/_ah/warmup.
There's some default behavior
that you can read.
Particularly, this is enabled
by default in Java, but
disabled for Python.
So in Python, you definitely
want to turn that on manually.
And then there's some ways to
override the servlet handler
there for Java applications.
Now, I said that was
the last thing.
There's one little tiny tip
here, which is avoid the
default error message pages.
When you have problems with
your application, you can
define your own error pages,
both in Java and Python.
It's pretty simple, just a few
lines of configuration.
And you pointed at a
nice pretty file.
IEIN VALDEZ: So, you can make
a beautiful error page.
FRED SAUER: You make a
beautiful error page.
Now maybe one with kind of a
robot that's all broken in
parts or something like that.
IEIN VALDEZ: Very cool.
FRED SAUER: So I think we have
some questions lined up.
IEIN VALDEZ: Yep, there
are some questions.
So I'm going to go ahead and go
to the Moderator, and I'll
just read through the ones we
have, and we'll try to answer
them as best we can.
So I'll just read them
out to you, Fred.
So here's one, from DP in Italy,
which is, "Do task
queues influence performance?
Any tips about task queue
performances?"
FRED SAUER: There's a lot to
say about task queues.
The way we kind of refer to
requests, there's two types.
We have online requests
and offline.
Online is anything user facing,
so a client coming in
making a live request.
Kind of think of it as a live
body or a hot Android device
behind that request.
And then offline requests are
all the background stuff.
So that's a task
queue in CRON.
And the App Engine scheduler
treats online requests and
off-line requests a little
bit separately.
It knows that you might have
offline requests that are a
lot slower than online ones.
In fact, if you have any kind of
slow operation, you should
probably move it to a task
queue so that your online
requests stay nice and fast.
But App Engine will treat those
two classes of requests
differently.
In fact, it will look
at the different
queues that you have.
So if you have a named queue Fu
and another queue named Bar
and they have different
performance characteristics,
App Engine scheduler will take
care of them separately.
There are a number of knobs
that you can tune in the
queues.yaml in Python or the App
Engine queue.xml in Java.
You can configure the maximum
rate of each queue, I think,
up to 100 requests per second.
IEIN VALDEZ: 100 is
the max, yeah.
FRED SAUER: And then you can
also configure, I believe, the
number of concurrent requests.
At least--
IEIN VALDEZ: There's a rate.
There's a rate, and
then there's a
bucket size, and something.
FRED SAUER: Yeah, buckets
and refill size.
We have a nice link to a
Wikipedia article about bucket
counters and how they work.
But the main thing there is
you can crank up the rate.
IEIN VALDEZ: And I'd also say
I think we did a couple of
Hangouts recently specifically
on task queues.
Amy did one, and
then I think--
FRED SAUER: That
was a good one.
IEIN VALDEZ: Danny
did one as well.
So there's some good-- you
should look at the Hangout
resources recently that we've
done specifically to task
queues I think that
were pretty cool.
FRED SAUER: But I think to
come back to the main
question, you shouldn't worry
about tasks influencing the
performance of your
online requests.
IEIN VALDEZ: So they're
sort of orthogonal.
FRED SAUER: Yeah, so what you do
in the background in batch
shouldn't negatively impact
the user experience.
In fact, I would also say
the reverse that--
or sorry, say something
different, which is anything
that is slow in your
online requests.
So if you have a request that
takes a long time, you should
almost always see if you can
move that, perhaps to a task
and respond back to the
client more quickly.
Because what you want on
the front end is really
performance requests,
and on the back end.
You want these slow
batch things.
Hope that answers
the question.
IEIN VALDEZ: OK, cool.
Yeah, all right.
Let's go--
there's a couple of new
ones popped up here.
One that we'll just deal with
real quick, which is from
Anonymous/Other.
"Any plans to create cloud
endpoint generation scripts
for Python with ProtoRPC?"
So this is just a random App
Engine question, but it's
related to Cloud endpoints.
I don't know the answer
to that question.
Dan Holevoet, who is running the
Trusted Tester Program for
Cloud Endpoints would be happy
to answer that question.
So if you're not already in the
Trusted Tester Program for
Cloud Endpoints, go ahead
and join, and Dan
can answer your question.
There's a whole forum
set up for that.
Good question.
OK, here we go.
Here's one from Nelson
in San Francisco.
This is a Python one.
"How does the number of WSGI
app instances affect
performance?
Is it generally better to try
to bundle URL routes into a
fewer number of apps or split
URL routes across multiple app
instances?"
FRED SAUER: Across multiple
app instances?
Oh, I would say that doesn't
really matter.
What does matter is perhaps the
overall memory footprint
of your instance.
So if you're duplicating some
data across those app
instances, that's not going to
help, although in most cases
it probably won't matter,
because you're probably not
hitting an instance threshold of
your F1 class or F2 class.
These types of tweaks are
unlikely to really help.
What you do want to do is
absolutely make sure that you
have Thread Safe set to true,
so you have multithreading
enabled for Python.
That only works in Python
2.7, of course.
You should be using Python 2.7,
which is better at of
scheduling.
IEIN VALDEZ: Yeah, I agree.
I think that you don't really
gain anything by it.
FRED SAUER: Don't
worry about it.
Organize your code, especially
in Python, for the way that
makes sense and productive
for you.
The big things to worry about
are enable multithreading
using Python 2.7, using the
task queue where you can.
The really big hits that you
can do are those datastore
performance tips, like doing
fetches instead of queries.
And wherever you're making a
call to another App Engine
back-end service, whether it's
memcache, or datastore, or
even URL fetch, do those
asynchronously, if you can, if
you're doing multiple, so that
you can do them in parallel.
If you need to fetch five
things from another web
service, issue those five calls
via an async call, and
then wait for the response.
And all five will happen at once
rather than sequentially.
Those are the big wins.
IEIN VALDEZ: OK, here's another
question from Nelson.
This is sort of a general
purpose question, which is,
"Is it possible for App Engine
to release global stats for
some benchmarks to help drive
design and modeling of
applications?
So, for example, what's the
average upper bound for entity
write opps?
Is 20 write opps average for an
entity with end properties?
Is 40 too high?" So, yeah, I
don't know what the guidance
is on like specific bounds.
FRED SAUER: Yeah, so these sorts
of things really depend
on the types of application
you have.
You can take some hints from our
examples and the way are
our APIs are going.
So if you look at, in Python the
DB API versus NDB, you see
that in NDB, the newer API, we
support structured properties,
which are kind of nested
properties within a single
entity group.
I think we've done a better job
now at telling you to make
sure that your properties are
not indexed by default,
because you have the extra
costs that the datastore
writes every time you update
the properties.
We've added support for
projection queries so that you
don't have to fetch all the
properties from the datastore.
So you see some strong hints
there that more properties are
definitely expensive.
We have support for list
properties, which is a way of
kind of efficiently
packing things.
So I'm not sure that
those statistics
would be that useful.
But the practical advice of
fewer properties, fetch only
what you need.
Do it as efficiently
as possible.
Pick your keys.
Turn off indexes for things
you don't need.
All of those things will have
fairly big impacts.
But at the end of the day, if
you need another property on
an entity, you should have it.
What you should be wary of is
lots and lots of properties,
lots and lots of indexes.
If you get anywhere close
to the limits of--
I think you can have 200
custom indexes on an
application or something like
that, if you're anywhere even
in the ballpark of that, you're
probably not organizing
your application the
way you want.
You may actually have an
application that's more suited
for using Cloud SQL rather than
the datastore, which you
can do in App Engine.
You can use a SQL instance
that will allow you the
relational queries and the
indexes that you need.
IEIN VALDEZ: Right.
OK.
Couple--
let's say we have about five
minutes, so we have a couple
short ones here, and then
there's kind of a bigger one
we can deal with at the end.
One is, "Should you be
doing async calls in
deferred/offline tasks too?"
FRED SAUER: If it allows you
to do things in parallel,
absolutely, yes.
So when you can make two URL
fetch calls at once instead of
after each other sequentially,
or you can do a batch get from
memcache to fetch three keys
instead of fetching one after
the other, those are
always beneficial.
The number of instance
hours that your
application needs is--
in an ideal world, it's very
simple to calculate.
You look at the average response
time for a request.
Let's say it's 100
milliseconds.
And if you're in a
single-threaded environment,
that means you can handle
10 requests
per second, per instance.
Now, with multithreading, you
can do a little bit more.
In the real world, your input
traffic is a little more--
what we call stochastic
or random.
So requests don't come in like
a heartbeat, where every 100
milliseconds you have a
new user coming in.
They come in kind of
bursts, and there's
some peaks and valleys.
And so the schedule has to
deal with kind of those
inefficiencies, and your
application does.
But your goal as a developer
is really to make your
requests finish as quickly
as possible.
That means doing things in
parallel, doing things
efficiently, and the faster you
get done, the happier your
users will be, the fewer
instance hours you will need,
the more efficient the
scheduler can be.
IEIN VALDEZ: Cool.
OK here's a question from
Joaquin in Sweden, which is,
"Are there any gains in speed to
be made by rearranging the
filters of a merge/join Query?"
I don't know the
answer to this one, actually.
FRED SAUER: There are--
so I'm probably not the best
person to answer that.
But I will say one thing that
would matter, which is in the
Dev App server when you run
different queries, it will
automatically update your
index.yaml or your App Engine
indexes.xml, and it will put
all the custom indexes that
you need in there.
Now, each of those indexes has
a write cost associated with
it for all the properties that
are referenced in that index.
If you set up your filters and
your queries in such a way
that you somehow are able to
reuse some of the indexes,
then any time you do a write
to any of those entities
affected, you would have fewer
writes, and those costs could
potentially be significant
or at least noticeable.
I'm not sure that it matters
too much to rearrange the
filter operations within a
single query, but it certainly
helps to think globally about
the types of indexes that you
have and to see where you can
have reuse and have fewer
index writes.
IEIN VALDEZ: Yeah, for sure.
And by the way, this is a great
question to post on
Stack Overflow.
So a lot of our team actually
monitors Stack Overflow as
well as some of the
engineering team.
So if you're not satisfied with
this answer, put it on
Stack Overflow using the
Google App Engine tag.
FRED SAUER: Yeah, that's a
good one for an in-depth
analysis discussion.
IEIN VALDEZ: Yeah, this
is a really good one
to talk about there.
So we have time for
one last question.
Basically, there's a discussion
in the public App
Engine group related to Deadline
Exceeded Exceptions
for big jar files.
So I think this is
like loading.
And the gist of the question
is, well, what are the
conclusions?
And I guess you have to look at
the thread, and we probably
don't have time to do
that right now.
But the subject is Java instance
startup time, and I
think it's related to having big
jar files and some errors
that that can cause you upon
loading requests and so forth.
FRED SAUER: I think this is
actually probably another good
question for Stack Overflow.
This is also a question where
the answer six months ago
probably would have
been a little
different than it is today.
We've done a number of things
to really help Java
applications out during their
startup and initialization.
It still remains true that the
fewer jar files you have, the
less work that you do in
initialization, the more that
you turn on warmup requests,
these things will help.
App Engine is a little bit
different from a lot of
infrastructure that many of us
are used to for on premise and
infrastructure as a
service in that
there's a lot of popular--
let me say it this way.
There's a lot of popular Java
frameworks that were built and
designed when the way to run a
web service or an application
was to have a number
of servers,
let's say five servers.
And they all start up, and it's
OK for them to take 5, 10
minutes to physically start up
all the way up and running,
and then to leave them running
for days or weeks and do
occasional maintenance
windows.
You know, on Sunday
night, we'll shut
down for a few hours.
App Engine is a very different
environment, where we're
constantly spinning up new
instances to handle new
traffic, shutting others down,
more than 100,000 applications
on App Engine right now that are
all kind of vying for the
same shared resources.
So the engineering trade-offs
are a little bit different.
We're looking for very fast
startup so that we can adjust
the scheduler in a very
fine-grained manner to adjust
to your traffic.
Now, if you have one of these
applications that uses these
kind of heavier frameworks
that just need longer
initialization time to
really come from--
I don't want to say an era of,
but a time not that long ago,
where these are the types of
framework that we used, App
Engine does have some
knobs for you.
Those performance-tuning knobs
I mentioned before, there's
that Min Idle Instances.
And if you enable warmup
requests, and you just crank
up the Min Idle Instances, maybe
even just a little bit,
App Engine will always keep
however many you specify
instances ready that are
pre-warmed up, ready to take
on new traffic, not having
to wait for the
initialization time.
In the extreme case, there's
kind of an advance tip that I
can go into.
This is not for everyone, but
this is one technique
that you can use.
If you have an application that
really wants to do a lot
of startup initialization, and
it's going to take you even
more than the 60 seconds, and
you've exhausted Min Idle
Instances, for those Java
applications, be sure you're
trying the F4 front-end
instances or even starting up
maybe a back-end instance in
doing a B8 because it will
give you more CPUs, start
up more quickly.
If you've exhausted all of that,
there is a technique
that you can use, which is
when you've received your
first request, do some of
the initialization.
Let's say do half the
work that you can.
And you set a little global flag
and a static variable and
say, OK, I've done the first
half of my initialization.
And then instead of returning
the response, because you know
you're not fully initialized,
you actually send back a 302
redirect to the client, and you
tell it to go back to the
exact same URL that
it just requested.
So that client gets the redirect
response, and it will
just send that request again.
And hopefully, it will hit a
different instance that's
already warm and the client's
taken care of.
If it's unlucky enough to hit
the same instance, that's
still all right.
Now your instance has gotten the
second request, but it's
had those 60 seconds to do the
first half of the warmup.
You look at the static variable,
you go, oh, I need
to do the second half of
my initialization.
You do that, and then you
serve your response.
IEIN VALDEZ: That's tricky.
FRED SAUER: So it's is a complex
case, but what we're
really doing here is we're
saying, well, the
initialization time of your
application, because of the
frameworks you're using and what
you're doing, if you add
that plus the time it takes to
handle an individual response,
those two together, if they
exceed that 60-second limit on
an F4 class instance, then this
is a technique to break
those apart.
The warmup request tries to
break up the first part from
the second.
This kind of advanced technique
I described is a way
to take that initial part and
even break that further down
into pieces.
So those are tricks
that you can use.
IEIN VALDEZ: Very awesome.
FRED SAUER: But higher
instance classes can
definitely help there.
That's what they're there for.
IEIN VALDEZ: Perfect.
Awesome, I think we're
out of time.
FRED SAUER: OK.
Well, thanks for--
IEIN VALDEZ: Thank you
for having me.
FRED SAUER: I enjoyed
it, yeah.
And thank you for all
your questions.
Really appreciate it and
hope to be back soon.
IEIN VALDEZ: OK, and we'll see
you next week, and be sure to
check out Stack Overflow
as well.
That's a great resource for
questions and answers.
FRED SAUER: Yep,
we're on there.
[MUSIC PLAYING]